[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo América de
Francia 24 por supuesto con nuestra
periodista especializada mar Romero sala
mar Hoy es un día importante porque ese
día mundial del corazón y vamos a hablar
de este órgano vital también de las
enfermedades cardiovasculares
cardiovasculares que nos aquejan Buenos
días Raúl Así es es muy importante que
dediquemos este espacio hoy porque es
que las enfermedades cardiovasculares
son la principal muerte causa de muerte
en todo el mundo es el motivo por el
cual más personas mueren y por el cual
más personas viven años de su vida con
discapacidad o con problemas no de
formas no sana es muy importante también
decir la gran inmensa mayoría de estas
muertes son evitables luego revisaremos
pues Qué factores de riesgo hay además
han ido creciendo a lo largo de los años
no a principio de los 90 aproximadamente
se morían unas 12 millones de personas
al año por enfermedades cardiovasculares
esta cifra ha ido en aumento
progresivamente hasta llegar a los 18
millones
900 otros 18 y medio Pero bueno ahí ven
esa línea roja que tiene esa Pues esa
franja señala precisamente como como
oscila esas estimaciones no es un
crecimiento que se debe en parte pues al
crecimiento de la población mundial eso
es uno de los motivos que no podemos
negar pero también porque ha ido
aumentando la carga de esta enfermedad
cada vez más personas se aquejan de
enfermedades cardiovasculares también es
una gran parte de las muertes prematuras
del 40% de las muertes prematuras se
consideran esas que están por debajo de
los 70 años se atribuyen a las
enfermedades cardiovasculares y
importante también el 85% de las muertes
cardiovasculares son por infartos o por
ataques al corazón justamente ahora
estábamos hablando de los síntomas de
Cómo saber si esto era un problema o no
si estábamos teniendo algún problema
Bueno yo quiero aquí hacer un apunte y
es que muchos conocemos los síntomas que
aquejan a los hombres no del infarto no
sé si tú los los has escuchado Raúl sí Y
como que dificultad como como si uno
tuviera algo atragantado en la garganta
dolores en el brazo derecho Exactamente
Bueno pues eso algo que sucede ahí es
que esos síntomas que son tan conocidos
son principalmente los síntomas que
ocurren en los hombres cuando un hombre
está teniendo un ataque al corazón y es
muy distinto en el caso de las mujeres
Eso hace que a pesar de que las
enfermedades cardiovasculares aquejen
principalmente a los hombres
precisamente por esos factores de riesgo
que ahora vamos a hablar también pasa
que muchas mujeres no reconocen que
están teniendo ese ataque al corazón
porque los síntomas son ligeramente
distintos por ejemplo las mujeres antes
de esperar ese dolor punzante se siente
más como un cansancio náuseas no pesadez
en el cuerpo en las piernas y estos
síntomas no han sido tan divulgados como
los ataques al corazón los síntomas del
ataque del corazón de los hombres y eso
pues hace que muchas mujeres lleguen
demasiado tarde a las urgencias a los
servicios de urgencias para que las
puedan atender pero aquí se los estamos
diciendo mal los principales riesgos
entonces a nuestro corazón
volvemos a los viejos amigos de siempre
a los viejos conocidos no el alma la
alimentación el sedentarismo el consumo
de tabaco de alcohol Bueno ya ya no hace
falta ya lo sabes Ya lo sabes todos No
aquí tenemos unos datos de la federación
mundial del corazón vemos que las
principales causas de mortalidad dentro
de estas enfermedades cardiovasculares
son pues la presión arterial alta
riesgos dietéticos colesterol alto y
también el tabaco que nos dice Esto
bueno que básicamente volvemos a todos
estos puntos que estábamos diciendo al
principio porque Qué provoca presión
arterial alta o colesterol alto todos
estos factores de riesgo que estábamos
explicando pero también de nuevo
queríamos hacer un apunte porque es que
el 75% más de hecho de tres cuartas
partes de las muertes por enfermedades
cardiovasculares se dan en países de
ingresos bajos o medios es decir que los
países con pocos recursos tienen mayor
carga que los países ricos y esto Pues
porque sucede Pues porque como vemos
venimos repitiendo también en estas
secciones de salud habitualmente
las posibilidades de tener una buena
alimentación o de ejercitarse
constantemente de tener eso el
colesterol bajo el consumo de alcohol
pues moderado suelen estar asociados
también con personas que tienen los
recursos para hacer todo esto entonces
de nuevo muchas veces insistimos en que
las enfermedades cardiovasculares son
algo que uno tiene que cuidar
individualmente no tienes que hacer
ejercicio tienes que comer bien no
puedes fumar No puedes tomar alcohol
Pero hay factores sociales que también
pues nos implican en todo esto que
tienen mucho que ver con nuestras clases
sociales con nuestras posibilidades de
alimentarnos bien o de tener una vida
saludable y eso pues no está al alcance
de todo el mundo al final el mar Pues sí
también todo recae en la alimentación no
tan importante y también en nuestros
hábitos yo creo que eso eso también es
muy importante y pues tener unos hábitos
saludables en la medida de nuestras
posibilidades Pues nos alargan la vida y
nos y nos evitan enfermedades que
podemos parecer en un futuro Porque le
da también avanza y a lo mejor los 31 no
lo ve Pero ya cuando uno entra a los 50
60 años ahí ve todo lo que hizo mal
antes y también ella que mencionabas el
futuro no y el paso del tiempo de hacer
mención especial al cambio climático
sabemos que es algo que nos va a afectar
transversalmente a todos en los próximos
años y ya actualmente la polución está
provocando 7 millones de muertes anuales
en enfermedades cardiovasculares es
decir es una carga muy alta que más allá
de los hábitos individuales personales
tenemos que enfrentar como sociedad
colectivamente porque el cambio
climático va a empeorar y va a hacer
crecer todavía más Pues esta carga de
enfermedades cardiovasculares en el
mundo mar como siempre Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información mañana
Por supuesto con más salud mañana más